Музичний привіт з 90-их.
Штори, ніби з бабусиних комодів.
Ікони в неналежному стані та в неналежному місці.
Колекції м’яких іграшок і вщент заліплені різними плакатами вікна.
Диво, що водій ще щось бачить на дорозі.
Пошарпані сидіння, жахливі поручні, двері в дірках та іржі.
І ось така собі вишенька на торті - міні-Новий рік на капоті і взимку, і влітку.
Все рівно буде Новий рік скоро! Чого його прибирати ? Може, забули, що він там є. Нехай собі їздить - катається.
У пасажирів київських маршруток від цього калейдоскопу голова йде обертом.
Кияни вже давно втомилися боротися з такою культурою пасажирських перевезень.
Мене дратує багато чого. Ось подивіться на маршрутку! Ось, приклад! Культури немає!
От це прийшов металолом. Тільки що мотор їде, його колеса тримають. Людей везе, як дрова! Немає про що розмовляти.
В маршрутках я б оновив сидіння. Потім це більш просторо і більш сучасно, це як пайпас.
І для чого ці іграшки? Явно не для дітей, які там в транспорті їздять. Я вважаю, що це зайве. Мінімум це пилюка. Для водія це якось несолідно.
Якщо музика гучна, то дуже дратує, це по-перше. По-друге, якби ще і водіям маршруток рівень культури підняти.
Я ось пенсіонерка, в нас же дозволений проїзд пенсіонерам за посвідченням. Випадково вийшло, що готівки не було. А треба було терміново їхати.
То водій мене обізвав і інвалідом, і ще кимось, але я принципово не вийшла.
Сідаєш в маршрутку , температура плюс  50 градусів. Всі потіють, дихають один на одного. Це не є ознакою цивілізованої столиці країни.
У маршрутці можна не лише спітніти, а й свідомість втратити.
Пасажири намагаються бути ближче до відкритих вікон та навіть в доволі небезпечний спосіб дверей.
Водії оснащують своє робоче місце вентилятором та обирають майже пляжний стиль одягу.
Вважаю, що водій має бути гарно одягнутий - в костюмі, краватці, сорочці, яку він, мабуть, не міняв цілий день.
Який кондиціонер? Якщо є вікна, значить відкриті. Ось вам і кондиціонер.
Якби в державі не було б корупції, так і автобус не був іржавим, або був кондиціонер.
Відповідь водія маршрутки на всі закиди - одна:
Хай ставлять кондиціонери, дають нам нову техніку, і ми будемо працювати. Дадуть форму, то будемо в формах  їздити!
Київська міська державна адміністрація натомість цього літа вирішила відповісти на усі багаторічні скарги пасажирів та прохання водіїв
запровадженням нових правил перевезень для маршруток.
У відповідь на запит DW Департамент транспорту повідомив, що водії мають бути в формі,
їм заборонено розміщувати в салоні зайві предмети, вмикати музику.
Вони мають оголошувати зупинки двома мовами - українською та англійською,
спілкуватися з пасажирами лише державною під загрозою розірвання договору на перевезення в односторонньому порядку.
В маршрутках має бути не менше 50 місць. Вони мають бути оснащенні системами охолодження та обігріву.
Наразі у Києві 150 маршрутів, на яких працюють майже 1500 маршруток.
І більшість водіїв, з якими говорила DW, сприймають нові правила, м'яко кажучи, скептично.
Заборона музики, державна мова в спілкуванні, кажуть, не проблема. А ось технічні вимоги виконати нібито нереально.
Це можна мріяти про це тільки.
А ви як би хотіли їздити?
Мені вже нічого не треба, бо я на пенсії.
На цих машинах теж можна працювати. Не ті умови, але працювати можна.
А кондиціонер?
В міському режимі, я вважаю, що його є, що його немає. Тут кожні 100 метрів відкрив двері-закрив двері.
Що він є, що його немає. Ні користі, ні шкоди. Може, якась краплинка в морі.
Проте нібито нереальне таки можна знайти на вулицях Києва.
У столиці вже з’явилися перші маршрутки, які відповідають новим правилам перевезень КМДА.
Приміром, на важкодоступній в транспортному відношенні Троєщині з’явилися сучасні маршрутки "Вольво".
Маршрутка має бути комфортною та головне - безпечною.
Сидіння мають бути оснащені ременями безпеки, як в цій машині. Щоправда, таких маршруток в Києві дуже мало.
Ці взірцеві маршрутки обслуговують 150-ий маршрут.
Фірма-перевізник - одна з восьми, які перемогли на конкурсі КМДА, який проводився в червні вже за новими правилами.
З восьми шість фірм  отримали контракт на п'ять років, бо відповідають новим вимогам. Дві фірми - лише на 2 роки, бо не цілком.
Диспетчер Леся Прекрасна працює на 150-му  маршруті і зізнається, що вперше отримує задоволення від своєї роботи.
Її колеги-водії вже одягли свою першу літню уніформу.
Водій охайно виглядає, на нього приємно дивитися.
Те, що музика не вмикається на всю потужність і пасажири не кричать, що, водій, вимкніть терміново музику.
По-друге, ви заходите до салону та відчуваєте цю прохолоду. Комфорт. Водій має право вимагати оплатити проїзд.
Але в нас є люди, які можуть не платити. Але він не буде з ними сваритися. Раніше було по-іншому.
Назви зупинок двома мовами. Водії наразі навчаються робити оголошення українською.
Є дошка з інформацією про фірму, куди скаржитися, зараз виготовляють таблички з даними водіїв.
Водій Сергій Ковбаса щойно працевлаштувався на маршрут і демонструє DW усі можливості машини, каже, що вперше працює в таких умовах.
Комфорт. Для нас, для водіїв та пасажирів комфорт. Робота двигуна не така гучна, умови роботи - посадка водія, сидіння "пілот".
Водії стареньких "Богданів" не дуже вірять у фінансову успішність сучасних маршруток в Києві.
Скажімо, взяти "Вольво ", "Мерседес "-  це  дуже дороге задоволення, а його пускати містом,  щоб він їздив...
Я не знаю, скільки він має заробляти, щоб себе окупити.
Нещодавно ціни на проїзд в маршрутках були підвищені до 10 гривень.
Експерти не виключають, що це не останнє подорожчання цього року.
Власники маршруток нарікають на погані прибутки за минулий рік, коли через пандемію маршрутки простоювали.
А щоб виконати нові правила, перевізникам потрібні чималі ресурси,
вважає радник голови правління Асоціації відповідальних перевізників Олександр Дяченко.
Написані ж хороші речі, просто вони написані без урахування економічного контексту, і вони  фасадні більше зміни.
Деяким перевізникам це буде легше зробити, бо в них більш-менш нормальний стан автопарку.
Десь комусь це буде складно зробити, бо роздовбані ці нещасні "Богданчики"… Які там кондиціонери?!
Доведеться їм відмовлятися від бізнесу, займатися чимось іншим, можливо, їхати в регіони.
Але в те, що хтось зараз почне масово шукати гроші та вкладатися, я в це не вірю, бо це дуже великі ризики.
Експерт не виключає, що в місті може, приміром, розвинутися мережа ще більш комфортних шатлів,
які працюють в режимі таксі і набирають пасажирів онлайн заздалегідь.
Мерія Києва має, своєю чергою, амбітні плани щодо оновлення громадського транспорту, включно з закупівлею електробусів.
Зрештою маршрутки будуть вимушені виконувати нові правила перевезень, переконаний експерт.
Це умови договору. Якщо перевізник їх не виконує, його можуть позбавити можливості працювати.
Коли їх почнуть перевіряти, а це ж питання до КМДА.
Якщо буде вказівка, то будуть ходити і міряти з термометром температуру  і слухати, яка музика лунає.
З формою взагалі цікава історія, як це буле впроваджуватися…
Думаю, що будуть намагаються перевіряти принаймні найближчим часом, щоб відзвітувати, що ми зробили.
В умовах українських реалій, щоправда, не виключено, що дехто захоче перетворити нові вимоги до маршруток на чергову корупційну схему,
беручи чи даючи хабарі за дозвільні документи чи для уникнення перевірок.
Водії "Вольво" на 150-му маршруті на Троєщині знають про можливі перевірки, кажуть, що пасажири скаржаться вже і на них.
Люди не звикли до цього комфорту. Вони там кричать.  Є там кнопочки "стоп".
Вони ще цього не розуміють. Я їм це розповідаю. Хочете вийти, то натисніть "стоп". Воно все реагує у водія на табло.
Вони же звикли в маршрутці: "Мені на зупинці! " через весь салон.
Леся показує і інші  наслідки відсутності звички до комфорту чи то-пак елементарної культури…
Ось це з’явилося в перший же день.
…розповідає, що пасажири навіть сміття на кшталт паличок від кави з собою намагаються сховати в кондиціонер, який потім потрібно чистити.
Проте жінка впевнена, що Київ на порозі чергової транспортної революції, коли зміняться не лише маршрутки-водії-перевізники, а і пасажири.